-Performing "Lit Like This"
from his E.P. "All In,"
here's Skepta!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ -Got the girls, the cars,
the money in the bank ♪
♪ Keys to the house,
whip bigger than a tank ♪
♪ So much ice, it's a joke ♪
♪ Don't mistake it for a prank ♪
♪ When you're lit like this ♪
♪ You might need
to get a shank ♪
to get a skeng ♪
♪ How you go to jail for a M ♪
♪ He didn't even get a ten ♪
♪ Them boys snitchin' ♪
♪ They're rattin' on
their friends ♪
♪ He's a opp boy
can't pattin' up again ♪
♪ Back from the village with
a brand-new source ♪
♪ Another G.O.A.T. got
sacrificed of course ♪
♪ I don't like Passa ♪
♪ Black Lives Matter
but if a opp drops ♪
♪ I cannot feel remorse ♪
♪ It's money, murder
and sexual intercourse ♪
♪ Big smoke,
I never play the victim ♪
♪ Money hangin' on my neck ♪
♪ Tryna bring my brothas in
'cause it's a cutthroat world ♪
♪ That we livin' in ♪
♪ Still, if I had to pick
a side, I pick the gang side ♪
♪ Check the scoreboard,
they're losin' by a landslide ♪
♪ I see them hatin' on me
and I understand why ♪
♪ They know my name
in every city ♪
♪ This a franchise ♪
♪ Talk ish, jump ship,
watch it capsize ♪
♪ Put some money on
your skin fade ♪
♪ That's a flat line ♪
♪ We takin' champagne showers,
gettin' baptized ♪
♪ Bring some more Dom Perignon
for the bad guy ♪
♪ We got the money in the bank,
keys to the house ♪
♪ Whip bigger than a tank ♪
♪ So much ice, it's a joke ♪
♪ Don't mistake it for a prank ♪
♪ When you're lit like this ♪
♪ You might need
to get a shank ♪
to get a skeng ♪
♪ How you go to jail for a M ♪
♪ He didn't even get a ten ♪
♪ Them boys snitchin' ♪
♪ They're rattin' on
their friends ♪
♪ He's a opp boy
can't pattin' up again ♪
♪ I made her smile ♪
♪ She calls me Prince Charming ♪
♪ I don't care about the price ♪
♪ I'll just put my card in ♪
♪ I'll be fresher than your
boyfriend inside my coffin ♪
♪ I was born cryin',
I'ma die laughin' ♪
♪ You ever seen a friend
turn frenemy ♪
♪ Grew up in the hood where
all I see is jealousy ♪
♪ Brothers switched up on me
'cause I adjusted ♪
♪ I still love 'em but they can
never be trusted ♪
♪ Yeah, I know you see
what I just did ♪
♪ I came in a double R ♪
♪ Left in another car ♪
♪ GQ, top 5, I'm a cover star ♪
♪ I ain't gotta say names ♪
♪ You know who
the brothers are ♪
♪ Give 'em the green light ♪
♪ I make a boy famous ♪
♪ Hear them talkin' 'bout me
like they're newspapers ♪
♪ Who are they, though? ♪
♪ Who are you, though? ♪
♪ We only talkin' money
in the studio ♪
♪ We got the money in the bank,
keys to the house ♪
♪ Whip bigger than a tank ♪
♪ So much ice, it's a joke ♪
♪ Don't mistake it for a prank ♪
♪ When you're lit like this ♪
♪ You might need
to get a shank ♪
to get a skeng ♪
♪ How you go to jail for a M ♪
♪ He didn't even get a ten ♪
♪ Them boys snitchin' ♪
♪ They're rattin' on
their friends ♪
♪ He's a opp boy
can't pattin' up again ♪
♪♪
♪ Jimmy Fallon ♪
♪ Big small ♪
♪♪